[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
this is an iphone 12 pro max
and it's running the software that's
going to be on the next iphone
the 12 s or 13 or whatever it's called
it was unveiled
about a month ago at wwdc and it's ios
15. in this video i'm going to show you
all of the stuff that i think makes the
biggest difference the new stuff
in this new software now i'm going to do
a separate video
on ipad os 15 because
i've been using that for a while too and
that's a whole separate set
of features and hopes and
thoughts and expectations but again
that's coming in a later video so
definitely make sure to subscribe if you
haven't already
to be among the first to see that but in
this video let's focus on what's coming
to the iphone and i'm going to go in
order of
least exciting to most exciting to me
maybe your order is the same also how
about that new wallpaper eh i kind of i
kind of dig the new ios wallpapers i'll
link
some sort of collection of them below if
someone's hosting it somewhere
okay so number five the redesigned
stock apps yeah i said it the weather
app is kind of nice now
now i still can't forgive apple for
buying dark sky
and then just stealing it from android
like i literally hate that every day
that was the best android weather app
but they've been building all of that
information into the apple weather app
now and it's got a fresh coat of paint
over everything
there's these big full screen animations
sometimes it's sunny here and you can
see that if it's rainy you can see the
rainy animation
i imagine snow and hail would look
pretty cool too so that is nice the
iphone's new clock app also
looks mostly the same but one subtle
thing is it lets you type
the time for your alarm instead of
having to deal with the sliders all the
time so it's small
but i see that as a small win safari
is a little more controversial but it's
redesigned as well and it includes an
address bar
down here now at the bottom which yes
means it is by definition
more reachable but now it kind of moves
around a bit more fluidly
like it disappears when you scroll it's
looking pretty full screen all the time
but then you can swipe across it to
switch between your open tabs
and when you want to type in it it moves
back up to the top so it's a little more
fluid
i think it's going to take some getting
used to but then last but not least i
want to highlight
apple maps now it's been the butt of
jokes for many years
i still don't use it but they have been
relentlessly improving it
catching up to things like google maps
and adding features that are
pretty unique and interesting so this
new version has much more
detail and has a lot more 3d models of
various buildings and landmarks now
certain cities will get it much earlier
than others if you look through san
francisco for example
way more details way more trees and
buildings are modeled here
if you look through new york city
there's a couple skyscrapers mapped out
but
they don't show up at every zoom level
so it's still being built
and if you live in a smaller city well
you may never see this stuff
but it is cool that they're adding it so
all right then number four
facetime i'm separating this out from
the other apps because
it's pretty important and let's face it
a lot of iphone users are about that
face time life
they've added a bunch of uh tweaks and
improvements and new features here too
so there's spatial audio and facetime
now so in group face times people's
voices
come from the direction they're oriented
on the screen
there's a new grid view too so it's neat
you can see everybody
there's portrait mode added so you can
blur your background
and different microphone modes so you
can choose standard
isolating voices or wide spectrum
microphone modes depending on if you
have a lot of background noise you want
to cancel or if you want to keep the
vibe keep the coffee shop environmental
noise but there's two really
big new facetime features here share
play
and facetime events okay so share play
this is maybe something we're doing more
in
pandemic times than ever but you know
how if you're facetiming someone and you
want to watch something
at the same time as someone on facetime
now that's built into facetime so as a
feature you can listen to
apple music together with someone or
watch tv shows
or movies on apple tv with synced
playback controls
so one person pauses it pauses at the
same time for everyone
one person fast forwards or scrubs
around to show you something
it'll fast forward for you too way
better than trying to keep this in sync
manually and shareplay has a new api as
well so
obviously apps will be able to build in
and plug into this we currently have
the disney app and hbo and espn i'm
hoping for other stuff maybe like
spotify
maybe netflix youtube would be nice so
these will
these will be added hopefully in the
future but then also facetime calls can
now be events
meaning you can add them to your
calendar you can also share
a link to them which might sound like a
certain other couple apps we've been
using a lot lately like
zoom which means people on windows
desktops
and people on android phones can click
the link
and join a facetime call so you can
technically say you have
facetime on android now
[Music]
[Music]
all right feature number three is called
live text
and this i think is really smart really
cool so this is all done on device
and basically now any image you have
with text in it from your camera or just
anything in your gallery
you can long press the text in that
image
and it'll recognize it and let you do
anything you can normally do
with any other text you can select all
copy it paste it somewhere
you can translate it and i've been
messing around with this in various
images of all kinds
text printed even written text and it's
been pretty good at working really well
plus you can use that lookup feature to
get some serious suggestions
that are sometimes useful especially if
the name of the place
or company is somewhere in the text then
siri can find it siri's still not that
smart yet so it's got to be something
pretty obvious it does not work for
videos i've tried but it's it's pretty
great on a lot of photos
and also works uh with photos of animals
so i took a picture of this cat and
long pressed it and it tries to tell me
the breed i have no idea if that is the
actual breed of this cat but that's
pretty cool that it tried
and it's kind of approaching what google
lens has been doing for a while now but
even more intuitive since you can just
literally long press straight on a photo
without a separate app it just kind of
works this specific feature works with
devices with a12 bionic
or later so not every older iphone will
get this but it's pretty good
i just like it's catching up to google
lens now google lens will identify
more things like it'll just try to id
anything the shoes you're wearing the
type of car that drives by
and this is a bit more limited now but
maybe someday in the future this will do
all that stuff too okay so number two
notifications
now i'm still saying this with a caveat
which is that
they still have a long way to go
android's notifications have
forever been way better than ios's
notifications but they've made some key
improvements here and some stuff that
i'm happy to see first of all again
a fresh new coat of paint you can see
this new design with bigger
photo icons you know app icons to the
left i love that that right away makes a
pretty big visual difference and then
there's a new feature called
notification summary so if you don't use
your phone for a while basically if
you've
gone to sleep and wake up or you haven't
used it for a bit
it'll round up all your low priority
notifications and put them in one place
so that seems nicer than having to go
through the whole list and deal with
them all
i just don't know what what exactly
qualifies as the the low priority stuff
that shows up here is it just messaging
apps that get through
is it everything gets rounded up into
this i'm not exactly sure yet but then
you have extra control
over what notifications show up because
you can turn on focus mode
and the person you're messaging will
actually see that you have notifications
silenced and actually brings me to my
number one feature by far
focus modes so and this actually works
universally across
all your stuff so if you have an iphone
also your apple watch
and your ipad and your mac and as
someone who likes customization who uses
an android phone most of the time for
customization
this is the best like version of that
i've seen on the iphone in a while it
kind of feels almost like
separate profiles even though it's not
quite that check it out you can go into
your quick settings and
long press here and you've got a couple
focus
modes there's do not disturb there's
sleep mode but also
a personal and a work by default and
each of these settings
at a basic level let's different
notifications in
from different apps and different people
so do not disturb mode
silence is pretty much everything work
mode doesn't let your
fun apps notify you personal mode
doesn't let your work apps notify you
and so you can customize what those apps
are and who can talk to you
in each mode but then you can choose a
bunch of other settings about each focus
mode too so you can have them
automatically turn on or off depending
on location
or time of day and you can literally
choose
only certain home screens to show up
when you have
a focus mode activated so you can have a
home screen set up for when you're at
work
that doesn't show your distracting
social media apps and then when you
switch focus modes or you get home for
the day
you can have a separate home screen that
shows up with all that stuff or whatever
other focus mode
you want to create seems like you can
just make as many as you want a gym one
a driving one a reading a gaming one
whatever it's pretty sick and on top of
all that customization like i said they
sync across all your devices so
if you enable work focus mode on your
phone all of your stuff is in work focus
mode and then
you get home and home mode gets
triggered automatically for location
everything starts getting your personal
notifications again so that's pretty
sweet i made a video about why some of
apple's features
take longer to build and implement i'll
link it below like button if you haven't
already seen it
but it's a great video i recommend it
but that's it now of course
there's way more than just five new
things with ios 15. they had a whole
two-hour keynote so of course there's
lots of small stuff that didn't make the
cut for me
um things like improved spotlight with
way more siri suggestions
things like uh the improved offline
speech-to-text recognition which is
sweet and just various performance
tweaks and improvements but
generally i'm liking ios 15. it's
looking
and feeling a lot better and you can let
me know if you agree with the order of
my top five or not but it looks nice
almost as nice as my skillshare class oh
yeah that's right some of you may
already know
that i have made a skillshare class all
about like the way that i
create videos some of the review videos
you've seen
some of the latest videos on the channel
and how i go about that whole process
from end to end so skillshare for those
who don't already know
is an online learning community for
creatives where you can find thousands
of inspiring classes
to learn something you don't already
know so photography
illustration music making mkbhd videos
it's funny because i identify as
self-taught mostly like i
didn't go to school for most of the
things that i do here now
making these tech videos but i always
wish there was
there could have been something that i
could have followed along
that could help lay this sort of steps
and fundamentals out so that's kind of
what i've made is what i wish i had back
at that time and i've also gone through
other skillshare courses
to learn other people's perspective on
doing things like there's one
specifically on
iphone photography and filmmaking with
caleb and niles for a moment and you can
see the way they do things and the way
they think about things
and so just to get a variety of
perspectives you can just have one
skillshare account and then just watch a
bunch of different stuff there's no ads
on skillshare and they're always
constantly
just launching new premium online
courses so you kind of just sign up and
then just hang out and just
watch a bunch of stuff and collect as
much as you can so if you want to
check this stuff out if you're
interested at all i'll have a link below
with my link
early sign ups will get a free trial of
a premium membership which is pretty
sweet
and i'll see you over there thanks for
watching
catch you in the next one peace
you